los ataques masivos de esta madrugada en
diferentes partes de Ucrania comenzaron
aquí en la ciudad de saporilla en el sur
del país una provincia donde se Libra
parte de esa contraofensiva que llevan a
cabo las fuerzas ucranianas para retomar
territorio ocupado por las fuerzas rusas
desde el comienzo de la invasión aquí Se
oyeron diferentes ataques a partir de la
una de la madrugada los escuchamos
fueron bastante duros algunos hicieron
temblar las ventanas del Hotel luego se
supo que eran misiles ese 300 y las
autoridades dijeron que no alcanzaron
lugares civiles sino que habían afectado
comunicación y empresas de la
agricultura Sin dar mayores detalles y
poco Después empezó un ataque masivo con
drones kamikashi de origen iranís en
kiepi en otras regiones del noroccidente
del país en la capital la defensa
antiaérea logró al menos
controlar 30 de estos drones tres de
ellos adicionales lograron su objetivo
se cree que uno de ellos fue el que
atacó la ciudad de leópolis El
noroccidente del país donde según las
autoridades quedó destruida una
infraestructura fundamental según ellos
Sin dar también mayores detalles luego
desde la defensa aérea ucraniana se dijo
que el país no estaba en capacidad para
tener defensas aéreas en todo el
territorio ucraniano que es bastante
grande que se tiene en los frentes de
batalla para defender a las ciudades más
grandes especialmente quién y que
también para defender plantas nucleares
y lugares de infraestructura esencial
para el país pero esto no se pueden
repartir en ciudades también
especialmente en Leví que está bastante
lejos del frente de batalla y de allí
que muchas veces estos kamikaz o estos
misiles alcancen su objetivo no
solamente allí sino también como sucedió
la semana pasada la ciudad de cri-cri en
el centro del país